got away with throwing a party in my  dorm with over a hundred people in it  with my ra down the hall and i got the  janitor the next day to clean it up i  decided i wanted to throw a beer pong  tournament i'm an entrepreneur so i  charged people like five ten bucks to  enter the party was getting a lot of  hype but at the last second the house  that was supposed to throw it backed out  so i decided to step up and throw it in  my dorm problem was the aria was down  the hall so i decided to do my research  i found out my aria was on the  basketball team i knew if i invited  basketball players she wouldn't write us  up and that's exactly what i did so  these are the brackets you can see how  many people signed up and that's just  the people that played the party was a  success but the problem was the next day  it was gross the next day i asked a  janitor to borrow his mop and he ended  up cleaning the entire dorm just like  that i got away with throwing a party  down the hall from my r.a